[Music]
foreign
[Music]
to the Daily climate show where we track
the changes to our world and interrogate
some of the potential solutions to The
Climate crisis
now efforts have been too slow in the
Cinderella of climate action that's how
the head of the environment agency
described the UK's adaptation to the
impacts of climate change in a speech
today sir James Bevin warned that if the
UK doesn't adjust to the ever-changing
environment future Generations will be
left to pick up the pieces now this
comes as a new report predicts the
number of homes in England at risk of
flooding could nearly double in the next
30 Years which is pushing for more focus
on nature-based Solutions but what does
this mean well the national
infrastructure commission says dwell 12
billion pounds of investment in Drainage
Systems is needed for homes to adapt as
climate change brings more intense and
frequent heavy rainfall
but it's urged for nature-based
solutions to be looked into before
digging more pipes and sewers now among
the suggestions are roof Gardens where
the soil absorbs rainwater slowing down
the impact of heavy rainfall and Rain
Gardens too they manage rainwater runoff
from hard surfaces after downpours by
planting an attractive low maintenance
Wildlife friendly space
and ponds they can manage flood risk and
create habitats for many different kinds
of wildlife well I'm joined Now by our
climate reporter Victoria Seabrook so
hundreds of thousands more homes could
be at risk of flooding in the coming
years Victoria what are the main reasons
for this well essentially for all too
long we've been building waterproof
towns and cities when you think of your
where you live at home you go down your
street there's hard roofs hard wolves
paved driveways tarmac roads and so on
so there's nowhere for the water to to
go so of course it accumulates in
gutters and when you have very heavy
intense flooding it all builds up in
this way different to a river
overflowing so say which which happens
over a longer course of time and is a
bit easier to predict and the reason why
this is getting worse is partly because
of climate change the the air is getting
warmer it can hold more water and it's
concentrating rain into sort of smaller
heavier bursts that's why we're seeing
more of this kind of flooding and then
the other reason of course is
urbanization we are building more and
more and so the government advisors are
saying the government really needs to
start obliging developers when they when
they're building homes for example to
build in some of these solutions that
we've just heard about for example ponds
that may be a dry for a lot of the year
but then can fill up when when we have
these intense rain events now this
report on the increased risk of flooding
comes as the boss of the environment
agency also has issued a pretty Stark
warning to the UK about the need for
adaptation tell us more about that yes
exactly so he's warning about the impact
on the economy on health and crucially
on our critical infrastructure so if you
think for example of the 40 degree heat
wave that we had this Summer that affect
that disrupted rail travel that grounded
flights storm Arwen last year left one
million people people without power and
this is all because we've been a bit
better at cutting emissions which is the
cause of climate change then we have
adapting to the impacts and obviously
you need to tackle the root cause but
those changes are already in effect
think of it as like a big cargo ship if
you want to turn it it takes a long time
before you start to see the movement and
we haven't been so good at adapting to
those impacts that is a problem not just
in the UK but the world over generally
we've been a lot slower when it comes to
adaptation but the UK has had a lot of
criticism for this recently MPS warning
that the government lacked a grip
accusing it of a severe dereliction of
Duty and I think we will start to hear
more more strong criticism like this
until the government really Knuckles
down on on adapting the flooding being a
case in point okay Victoria we
appreciate your update thank you
now the government is to buy a 700
million pound stake in the size well C
nuclear power station it's a move which
will see China ousted from the project
it comes as the National Grid was close
to implementing its blackout prevention
scheme yesterday the French nuclear
power industry is currently in turmoil
and Supply is a warning that they are
struggling to cope with demand sizewell
C claims to generate around seven
percent of the UK's electricity needs
but with yesterday's wake-up call is
nuclear still the best path to energy
security well we can take a look at the
live power mix on our data dashboard
which shows that around 11 of our energy
is currently coming from nuclear today
well joining me now to give us a bit
more context on all of this is Richard
black senior associate at the energy and
climate intelligence unit a very warm
welcome to you Richard
well the government is investing nearly
700 million pounds in size well C now
which will end China's involvement can
we begin with your reaction to this
I think the government is taking what
you could call a more honest approach to
size well than it has to heat Clee which
is the sister station which is a bit
further along because basically they've
said this is a matter of national
necessity that's their judgment
um and therefore why doesn't the state
uh invest in it it is kind of
interesting to reflect that here we have
a conservative government which is
making a big state-led intervention in
energy policy
um when actually the the other
alternative the the Renewables and
storage uh uh uh Solutions uh side of
things is largely private sector
financed and basically all a government
has to do is sort of get the red tape
out of the way and let the money flow in
so you have a conservative government
doing something that in many people's
eyes I think would be um very
unconservative here
and Richard what risk do you think it
could have posed keeping China involved
in size well C
yeah hard to say I mean my belief has
always been you know I'm not an expert
in these things but um miles belief that
you know if if a if a if a if a
malicious actor wants to to take out a
part of the energy infrastructure
they're probably you know they'd
probably find a way
um so I'm not sure it matters that much
in terms of energy security China still
has you know a big stake in the North
Sea for example oil and gas production
um and um you know the bulk of the solar
industry
um the the production starts in in China
so you can't wipe China out of the
energy mix entirely now certainly it
does represent a U-turn in terms of the
UK's energy policy this investment this
huge investment in size world C is
nuclear the future do you think
no I don't think it is I think globally
it's going to be a bit part player in
the future I mean the number of nuclear
actors operating in the world and the
amount of electricity that they produce
has remain flat for about 20 years and
that's really because as time goes on
the Alternatives Renewables and storage
just look economically far more
attractive so you know from an
engineering point of view having a few
nuclear actors on the system producing
baseload power can make management of
the grid a bit easier at the moment but
there's no doubt that Britain could run
in the future with 100 Renewables
provided you have the backup from from
storage and demand response and all the
other things
now we nearly had to resort to that
blackout prevention plan yesterday Have
We Become too reliant on French nuclear
energy
I think you've got to have a diversity
of supplies and in the past it's proved
very Reliant you know it's proved quite
reliable to import electricity from the
continent and then at other times of the
year um British wind farms and so on
export electricity to the continent so I
think you know interconnecting cables
are gen are generally a very good thing
it's just that a lot of the French
nuclear Fleet is getting quite old and
they're having these reliability
problems problems which have also
cropped up in the UK a little bit as
well it's really the Confluence of these
different factors
um with you know low wind and so on and
gas prices being so huge but I think the
important point to uh to to to make is
that we didn't come close to a blackout
we came close to having to implement a
blackout prevention measure that's a
good thing isn't it
okay Richard it's been fascinating to
talk to you thank you so much for
joining us today thank you
thank you
time for some of today's other climate
news now and the prime minister is being
urged to lead the way on International
negotiations to secure a deal to reverse
biodiversity loss by attending cop 15.
the WWF is calling for countries to
commit to the goal of conserving at
least 30 percent of the world's land
wetlands and Oceans by 2030 at the
United Nations meeting in Montreal next
month the government has said it remains
absolutely committed in leading action
to tackle climate change and protect
nature and that the environment
secretary Therese Coffey will be
attending the talks
Australia's environment Minister has hit
back at a U.N report that has
recommended moving the Great Barrier
Reef to endangered status the UN
cultural agency and the international
Union for conservation and Nature's
report warned that without ambitious
rapid and sustained climate action the
world's largest reef is in Peril but
Tanya pilbasek said the report is a
reflection on Australia's previous
government and that her party are
already addressing the issues
highlighted if the Great Barrier Reef is
in danger then every every Coral Reef in
the world is in danger if this world
heritage site is in danger then most
world heritage sites around the world
are in danger from climate change we are
as a government absolutely determined to
do our bit to keep global warming
beneath one and a half degrees we've
legislated we've invested we're working
hard to make sure that that's the case
through all of our policies
and a type of seaweed that's been
discovered in the Antarctic region 100
meters below the surface could play a
huge role in protecting the environment
scientists were trying to find out the
maximum depth seaweed can live
underwater near Adelaide island off the
southwestern Antarctic Peninsula seaweed
is an important carbon sequestering tool
as it's able to store carbon and can
help to reduce ocean acidification
now Latin America contains some of the
world's most biodiverse forest
ecosystems yet more than 40 percent of
the Region's forests have been cleared
or degraded to make way for mining
Agricultural and infrastructure projects
now in the slopes of the Peruvian Andes
one man is leading indigenous
communities in a push to protect forests
which are critical for fighting climate
change
we have more than 25
000 indigenous families working along
all the Andes planting more than 60 000
trees in a single day
this is the communal world
it's better to work with the local
communities why they in the future they
are going to be engaged on the process
and they are going to be the perfect
allies because we are Reviving that and
seeing practice from the indigenous
culture
and winner of the UN champion of the
earth award the highest environmental
honor awarded by the UN Tino Alka joins
me now from Peru a very warm welcome to
you Tino thank you for joining us now
you've been involved in conservation for
decades describe how you see you've seen
your home change due to climate change
thank you so much for this interview ah
for me conservation and doing all
practices on ground with the real uh
Solutions is my mission it's my life
sometimes I think if I want to do
something concrete I mean going to do
whatever can be to
fight against the climate change
now you've been pushing local
communities to protect forests across
South America explain to us how you've
been doing that
uh I think that the war couldn't be
pushing I believe that planting 100
trees or thousand trees is not the
solution that probably is for the
picture in some front page of the
magazine the solution is to plant
millions of trees but who is going to
plant all that millions of trees of
course it's going to be with the
communities because communities has the
power because the organization and the
commitment to come and help me in this
program to plant all these millions they
can do it by Reviving this uh ancient
activity that is the communal work and
in that way is the only possibility that
we can do it that along all the Andes
and what do you hear about how climate
change is has impacted the life of
locals what do they tell you
uh every time the locals they they
are suffering all the time like this
year the rains are arriving after two
months most of the agriculture yes
collapsed and uh for them it's not they
don't tell that that is a climate change
they say it's something we are doing
wrong it's amazing to hurt all these
local community when they pointed me the
mountains where they lost the the snow
they said hey that that mountain 30
years ago was with the snow now no more
probably we are doing something wrong
and the mother earth is angry about that
imagine that uh that simple conclusion
if if the rest of the world can do it
the same thing probably the entire world
can take action and do whatever can be
to restore the work and stop all this
product that is coming on the name of
the climate change
what more help do you want to see from
the international community and what did
you make of what you've heard come from
them at the climate change Summit in
charmel Sheikh
sorry if I'm going to say this but is
the 27
meeting
what's the solution what's the
conclusion nothing of action it's only
agreements and agreements how many
meetings more we need to take action we
are fighting for two greats
and the world is claiming for that what
else we need to take action
please remember my my organization
actually is trying to do this along the
Andes and we are growing and growing
more
six million trees at the moment is not
nothing
we need to put more trees on the ground
and secure the water that is the most
important thing on the lives of all the
local communities
now you've previously said a rather
wonderful phrase you said we must work
hard to run faster than the destruction
do you have hope that the world will
eventually come together and do this
when I attend to the cup 14th in Lima
and after not seeing any result
what I did I get back home and United
all my community and say let's send a
message to the world what can we do it
if we are organized that day we planted
over 57 000 trees in a single day after
that we are not stopping
we are going to show to the rest of the
world with a concrete vessels with more
action what they have to do it
when I talk on the United Nations in
2018
I tell to everybody please
abandon Diego abandoned the comfort
communities are climbing for more action
and the mother earth needed
let's take her for this single home that
we are still living here
okay Tino Alka we appreciate your time
today and we admire your work thank you
so much for speaking to us thank you
Let's Take Action please
and reminded that on Saturdays and
Sundays you can catch Tom heaps climate
show that is on at 3 30 in the afternoon
also at 7 30 in the evening right here
on Sky News
but for now that is all from me thank
you very much for watching see you next
time
[Music]